protests against the government and the
monarchy have been held
in the thai capital bangkok today
protesters are demanding
greater accountability from the monarchy
after it emerged the king had
transferred the crown assets
to himself increasing his wealth
enormously
an under pressure government has
responded by invoking the country's
strict less majestic laws and charging
at least 12
protest leaders with defaming the
monarchy
now a lot of the anger is directed
against the current king
mahavajira long khan who spends most of
his time here in germany
his long stays have become a headache
for berlin
with the government being questioned by
the opposition on whether he actually
conducts state business from here
the government has said this would be
unacceptable
[Applause]
for months pro-democracy protesters in
thailand have been trying to send a
message to the king
reform our country and your monarchy
but the man they're addressing has often
been absent
thousands of kilometers away in fact
while protests raged on the streets of
bangkok
the thai monarch spent much of his time
in germany
in a luxury hotel in the southern
bavarian alps
his extended stays in the quaint area
have put the german government
in a bind berlin has been trying to
determine whether the king conducts
state affairs from his bavarian hideaway
the foreign minister has stated that
that would be a deal breaker for
germany's hospitality
obviously i'm also watching the thai
kings behavior in germany
we've not just been monitoring this in
recent weeks we are monitoring this long
term
if there are things that we consider to
be illegal there will be immediate
consequences
but that's easier said than done a
parliamentary investigation has found
that germany has
limited legal options because the king
enjoys diplomatic protections
like other visiting heads of state even
if he's there on private business
it's caused frustration among lawmakers
who commissioned the research
the left party serbian darulin had this
to say on twitter
anyone who like the thai king along with
a military junta
brutally knocks down the democracy
movement shouldn't be rewarded with a
visa for a luxurious long time stay in
germany
by the federal government
it appears germany has just one option
to take action against the king
and that's using a decades-old
international treaty on diplomatic
relations
parliamentary researchers said berlin
can declare the king a persona non-grata
or unacceptable person and expel him
from the country
but that option was described as a last
resort
it also carries the risk of a diplomatic
escalation of the political drama
that germany wanted no part in
[Applause]
for now there's less pressure on german
politicians
in mid-october the king returned to
thailand to the joy of his royalist
supporters
his critics are hoping he'll finally
address their grievances
and not return to his hideaway in the
bavarian mountains
many in germany are hoping for the same
felix hyduk is a senior associate at the
german institute
for international and security affairs
with southeast asia
as the focus area of his research felix
welcome
now there have been somewhat strong
words from the foreign minister haiku
mars
yet it appears according to the
parliamentary investigation at least
that there isn't much the government can
do about the hiking
here in germany how do we read this
well i read it as an interplay of
international
affairs basically and domestic affairs
and
actually in my view that's most
certainly the case
in most foreign policy making and here
as well so on the one hand
you have german media outlets repo
reporting very critically
on the thai monarchs extended visits to
germany as well as
on his role in current thai affairs plus
you have add to that
increased scrutiny by the opposition in
the parliament in the bundestag
so that domestically has put pressure
and
continues to put pressure on the
government in berlin to act and on the
other hand you have the demonstrations
in thailand
including those taking place in front of
the german embassy actually in bangkok
calling on berlin to act as well while
at the same time
the current thai government is cracking
down on on those pro democracy
protesters
so this is how i read the events
surrounding this issue
basically as the interplay of domestic
and international factors
however i would say with regards to the
future developments i'd say uh more
depends on
the developments in thailand rather than
what
the the domestic pressures in germany i
think much will depend on how
events will unfold in thailand in the
future we'll come to that in a minute
but what is the
wider geostrategic lens with which
germany is looking
at this whole affair
well there's the the geostrategic
context
is marked by an intensifying
sino-american rivalry
in the context of this power shift
towards asia that
that many people have been talking about
for for years now
to the whole of asia not just to china
so asia is
increasingly important to you
strategically and geo economically the
latter especially
to a trading state like germany and at
the same time
berlin has for long for quite some time
equated china with asia china
asia policy was basically china policy
and and vice versa
so this over dependence on china
especially economically is now seen
as a challenge for berlin and berlin now
in the context of also these
new pacific guidelines seeks
diversification
seeks new partners especially in
southeast asia um and the planned eu
free trade agreement with thailand is
one indicator of this
um so and at the same time you have the
military-led
thai government uh since the coup in
2014
move being ever closer to to china
due to what they perceive to be unjust
criticism of their internal affairs by
western states and so on and so forth so
i say this this conundrum is the
geo strategic context where we're
dealing with at the moment with regards
to
um german thai affairs right briefly
felix if you can how do you see this
playing out in the future if protests
continue in thailand
well i think short term not so much as
long as the king is
in thailand i think this will take um
the domestic pressure from the
government in berlin to a certain extent
and he's predicted to stay in thailand
actually for the rest of the year 2020.
i obviously
don't know but this is this is what i
hear um however if if the
king were to return in say early 2021 to
to bavaria that is right and protests
still carry on
in bangkok or even worse there's a
bloody crackdown
by the military uh i think the the
agenda will
the the this issue will be on the agenda
of berlin with
renewed urgency i would say felix
heyduck we leave it there for the time
being but thank you so much
for joining us
you